avec ces grandes oreilles sa robe
tachetée et son air sauvage ces traces
de chats abusent sa popularité exploser
ces dernières années
sur Tik Tok le mot clé Savannah Sha
cumule plus de 860 millions de vues et
la version anglaise Savannah 4 plus de
1,3 milliards ok en vrai c'est super
mignon mais ce que je savais pas c'est
que ce chat pose aussi plusieurs
questions à tel point qu'il a été
interdit dans plusieurs endroits du
monde le Savannah c'est pas une race de
chat classique il est le résultat d'une
hybridation entre deux espèces bien
distinctes l'une domestiques et l'eau de
sauvage le rêve de ses créateurs pouvoir
avoir dans son salon un chat l'apparence
de félins sauvage le bon intention en
voulant avoir juste un joli chat chez
soi on se rend pas compte qu'il y a une
cascade en fait de conséquences derrière
interdit ça m'a vraiment étonné pour ce
nouvel épisode de la grande explication
j'ai voulu donc comprendre d'où il
venait que cacheuse Savannah quel
crainte concrète suscite-t-il je vous
explique
ça c'est la toute première femelle de
Savannah elle s'appelle d'ailleurs
Savannah elle est née le 7 avril 1986 en
Pennsylvanie aux États-Unis à la
naissance elle pèse environ 220 g le
double d'un chaton normal les premiers
croisements ont lieu dans les années 80
et petit à petit a été est arrivé l'idée
de créer une race à partir de ce ces
hybrides en fait
semoise mais son père fait partie d'une
autre espèce non domestique le serval
le serval c'est cet animal sauvage il
pèse en général entre 9 et 18 kg entre 4
à 5 kg pour un chat évidemment il est
beaucoup plus grand que notre chat
domestique son habitat s'étend sur une
grande partie du continent africain
c'est l'un des félins qui a le meilleur
taux de succès à la chasse il capture
presque une fois sur deux et ça c'est
notamment grâce à ses grandes oreilles
Géraldine Véro m'a montré des spécimens
des collections du Muséum National
d'Histoire Naturelle récupérée par
exemple auprès des douanes c'est le
félin qui a les plus grandes oreilles
proportionnellement à sa taille et ça
correspond vraiment à son mode de vie de
détection des proies dans les hautes
herbes il y a aussi ces longues pattes
il va faire un saut sur la proie à
distance peut faire un saut de trois
quatre mètres de longueur de 3 mètres de
hauteur et c'est vraiment un spécialiste
de ce mode de chasse dans les années qui
suivent la naissance de Savannah
plusieurs éleveurs à éleveuses vont
tenté de faire reproduire sa descendance
pour créer une nouvelle race de chat aux
allures de petits Serval en 2000 la
tikka dit international 4 associations
des Savannah dans leur registre et leur
participation des expositions de chats
il y a eu d'autres exemples notamment
chez les chats puisque il y a le Bengal
qui est issu du croisement avec le
chaletopard qui est un peu plus ancien
et qui vient aussi des États-Unis mais
dans la nature c'est assez rare en fait
les espèces elles sont un peu séparées
et c'est bien pour ça que ce sont des
vrais espaces quelques années plus tard
c'est au tour du Louvre un organisme qui
encadre les chats de race en France de
le reconnaître le Savannah gagne en
popularité des élevages se développent
et le nombre de ventes se multiplient
sur les sites de vente son look sauvage
n'est pas le seul à tout mis en avant il
ne provoque pas d'allergie il est très
joueur et contrairement à d'autres chats
il aime l'eau mais ce chat hybride n'est
pas le bienvenu partout
aux États-Unis plusieurs états
interdisent la possession de Savannah la
Géorgie Hawaï Road Island ou encore le
neveraska c'est aussi le cas de
l'Australie en 2008 le gouvernement
craint que des Savana s'échappent et
menacent de nombreux animaux sauvages de
Lille en 2020 le Conseil bruxellois du
bien-être animal recommande à la région
de Bruxelles capital en Belgique de
l'interdire à son tour dans un rapport
cet organisme indique que les premières
générations de Savannah ne sont pas
adaptées à la vie en tant qu'animal de
compagnie pointe également leur manque
de fertilité en combinaison avec des
problèmes de bien-être liés à
l'accouplement et la gestation les
autorités de Bruxelles capital décide de
suivre le rapport et interdise la
détention de savane en 2022 plusieurs
associations demandent au gouvernement
britannique de suivre la même voix et en
France plusieurs ONG demandent aussi de
légiférer sur le sujet mais concrètement
ce chat peut-il vraiment poser problème
[Musique]
sur cette plaquette voici comment le Loo
l'organisme qui encade les races en
France présente le Savannah le Savannah
est très doux dès les premières
générations comme tous les autres chats
il dort sur les genoux et mange des
croquettes il s'adapte bien à la vie
intérieure même si son énergie est
débordante une première inquiétude vient
du caractère chasseur de son ancêtre
Serval on sait déjà que le chat
domestique pose des problèmes éventuels
sur la biodiversité notamment dans
certaines conditions comme les îles par
exemple où il y a des espèces qui n'ont
pas connu d'autres prédateurs donc ça
peut poser déjà des problèmes mais là on
se retrouve avec des chats beaucoup plus
efficaces beaucoup plus gros
physiquement le Savannah est plus
imposant il peut dépasser les 10 kg
contre 4 à 5 kg pour les chats
classiques les Savannah ont obtenu à
plusieurs reprises le record de plus
grand chat du monde en Australie des
scientifiques ont mené une étude en 2019
selon leur calcul les Savannah
pourraient s'attaquer à 28 espèces de
mammifères de plus que les 168 qui
peuvent déjà être chassés par le chat
domestique classique au total
l'introduction du Savannah
représenterait un risque pour 91% des
espèces de mammifères maintenant volant
existante d'Australie pour cette équipe
ce résultat valide fortement la décision
d'interdire les Savannah d'Australie où
on sait qu'il y a énormément d'espèces
qui ont été introduites notamment de
d'Europe et composé un grand grand
problème pour beaucoup d'espèces
endémiques locales qui n'existent là
quand elle s'éteigne c'est fini et qui
se protège en fait de ça pour la
biodiversité je me suis demandé
qu'est-ce que ces origines sauvages
changeaient en tant qu'animal de
compagnie il garde quand même ce côté
sauvage mais c'est peut-être ça qui
attire les gens aussi mais
malheureusement c'est ça aussi qui fait
que beaucoup sont abandonnés que
beaucoup finissent dans des cages ou
vraiment dans des conditions parfois pas
très bonnes en France l'étudiant de
vétérinaire sarah slor a interrogé 57
propriétaires de Savannah et 5700
d'autres chats ça thèse publie en 2019
elle révèle plusieurs différences les
Savannah étudiés paraissaient moins
peureux ils présentaient davantage de
comportements de marquages urinaire
mieux les avantages de manière excessive
ou encore se montrer plus turbulent ou
énergique elle conclut que les Savannah
semblent tout de même adaptés un mode de
vie urbain en tant qu'animaux de
compagnie malgré leurs origines sauvages
mais il y a encore autre chose qui
inquiète
nous sommes le 3 mars 2018 à Juvignac
dans l'Hérault un habitant apeuré signal
un léopard sur son toit qui tenterait de
s'attaquer à ses poules les pompiers et
les gendarmes arrivent pour tenter de
capturer l'animal pour eux ce n'est pas
un léopard mais un chat Savannah nouveau
rebondissement quelques jours plus tard
la gendarmerie indique sur Twitter
qu'après vérification le foleopard
n'était pas non plus un Savannah mais un
Serval cette histoire c'est loin d'être
la seule confusion entre Savannah Serval
voir d'autres félins et les favoriser
par la faible connaissance de ces
animaux et par leur ressemblance elle
peut avoir des conséquences importantes
au Royaume-Uni mais aussi en France
plusieurs ONG constatent une hausse du
trafic de Serval depuis la mode des
Savannah il y a beaucoup plus de saisie
du trafic de Serval donc la vraie espèce
sauvage et qui souvent était
on va dire identifié par leur
propriétaire comme des Savannah mais
probablement pour les faire passer pour
des servales en septembre 2022 leur
inflige ton gataire d'accueil qui avait
dû accueillir plus de 10 Serval en
quelques mois alerte les trafiquants
jouent sur la légalité du Savannah pour
vendre des servales en tant que Savannah
le serval même si c'est une espèce qui
est pas en grand danger à des
populations qui sont en grande danger
c'est une espèce aussi qui subit aussi
beaucoup de transformation de son
habitat de perte d'habitat et donc
forcément une menace supplémentaire avec
le trafic pourrait vraiment
la mettre dans une situation de
conservation problématique
ce qu'on n'a pas encore dit c'est qu'il
y a une histoire de génération qui joue
beaucoup sur les prix la ressemblance au
Cerval et les comportements dans les
annonces de Savannah que j'ai trouvé les
prix allaient principalement de 1000 à
10000 euros mais dans certains cas ils
peuvent atteindre les 20000 euros en
fait chaque Savannah possède un code qui
commence par la lettre F et fin F2 F3 F4
ce chiffre il correspond au nombre de
générations qui séparent le Savannah
d'un Serval il a un parent qui est
Serval l'espèce le félin sauvage l'autre
parent est un chat domestique donc c'est
le premier hybride descendant d'un
croisement entre ces deux espèces et F2
il va avoir un grand parent la
grand-mère ou le grand-père qui est
l'espèce sauvage c'est ça c'est F1 F2 F3
F4 à chaque fois le parent Savannah
était reproduit avec un chat domestique
cela veut dire que chaque génération
possède de moins en moins de 100 Serval
c'est pour ça qu'un F6 par exemple coûte
bien moins cher qu'un la thèse dont je
vous ai déjà parlé explique que les
mâles demeure souvent stériles jusqu'à
la génération F4 mais que les femelles
peuvent être fertiles dès la génération
F1 et l'indique aussi que même si les
générations ultérieures ont un
comportement plus domestique que les
générations F1 nombreux sont les
individus qui présentent des traits de
caractères et des comportements de type
sauvages et tout ça nous dit pas encore
vraiment si on peut en avoir un chez soi
ou non
[Musique]
d'accueil demande une réglementation
plus stricte voir son interdiction afin
d'éviter des traitements inadaptés un
impact sur la biodiversité ou la
confusion avec le serval personnellement
mon rôle c'est pas de dire c'est bien ou
pas d'avoir un Savannah je suis sûr
qu'il existe plein d'éleveurs haute
propriétaire qui connaissent très bien
leur Savana et en prennent le plus grand
soin mais avant de potentiellement
acheter ces traces de chat je trouvais
quand même intéressant de vous parler de
ces différents aspects que j'ai
découvert moi-même très récemment
[Musique]
j'espère que vous aussi vous avez appris
des choses ou que cette vidéo vous a plu
et si c'est le cas vous pouvez cliquer
sur le pouce juste en dessous de la
vidéo bon ok ça paraît un peu cliché de
dire ça mais en fait ça permet vraiment
à plus de personnes de découvrir
potentiellement cette histoire on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouvel épisode de la grande explication
sur l'environnement ou les animaux à
bientôt